not only are you gonna redo the means
you are gonna become the means you get a
car and you get a car and everybody gets
the car it's not often that I can say
immediately that's gonna break the
internet this body just Rorty in and
they're left go here in New York City
well we're gonna meet up with rookie
Quintin Williams of the Jets
listen thing I'm gonna go play with
myself today I kind of weird
unfortunately we got a flat tire so I'm
gonna use my statefarm mobile apps to
get some roadside assistance this is
definitely Manhattan definitely just
like this is definitely not just a bit
that we wrote to feature a State Farm
mobile app let's go talk to Quinn and
William shall we ditch the playbook
[Music]
let's go big Q welcome to bleacher power
my name's dope man you're pretty much
like a walking meme as it is oh yeah
so let's make you the king of the
Internet this is our meme laboratory our
meme factory is the dope there are memes
out there that I think are great but
they could be better not only are you
gonna redo the means you are gonna
become the means okay I'm so heavy I got
a teacup I was just thinking my ear like
how do we got we got you set up for
everything what does the Kermit tea mean
when would you use that I somebody got
tea so it's sort it really means that's
none of my business
oh so he's just gonna sit there and
drink his tea awesome I just
I've got it I'm tired of Kermit I need
you to do it
that was perfect how did you feel about
that did that feel up to your artistic
yeah Evers it definitely good I feel
like Vin Diesel our next one is going to
be oh that's not for this one I got
another one you like this guy so when
would you use this meme like nothing
when somebody face home or somebody
asked me a question then they already
know I'd like like think about it bro
like see this to me is you rush the
quarterback and you go oh this is way
too easy
screen you make the tackle and people
are like wow you're just like there's
one more thing we need to do oh yes I'll
look this is their first mustache ever
ever dude your whole energy is different
now that you have a mustache Oh
whoa that sure does look good do you
know who that guy is
Adam Adam Schefter editor a big dude
everything an Adam Sandler that's Chris
Farley they hung out a lot when would
you use this for football after Le'Veon
jute like two three people who holy crap
so to sell this you're right it's all
about the glasses is definitely buy the
glasses need the perfect laughs that's
awesome how that one feels no I like
doing so this is this is after a win
yeah
this is after a sack fumble recovery for
a touchdown this is this is you get a
chance to meet Aaron Rodgers after a
game I seen era that he look he like
he's getting old maybe out of my stairs
and he looked funny now you were all the
ger yeah I mean I guess you can call
your Rodgers old if you feel confident
I'm gonna be careful then we need you
dressed like Oprah though Oprah and we
see look at this Rick James is in the
house everybody how do you feel right
now
I feel that's awesome it's not often
that I can say immediately that's gonna
break the internet there's definitely
gonna breathe in there that hasn't
bothered just Rorty Internet I know he
likes it because we're facetiming
everybody to me when you have an
incredible play this is the one the top
five meme of all time yeah I need to
come out of screen and then be like
I got my part already there yeah your
parts done
my parts the hard part okay you ready
kill ya can't me - are you ready to see
these spread all over the internet I'm
definitely ready man I know for Shawn be
using her I know show my fans and the
Jets fans and amazing will be used so
they dope
now we're gonna play my favorite me my
man it was awesome either do you guys
have it
hi I'm Jonathan Abrams safety of the
Oakland Raiders subscribe to bleacher
report on YouTube for more of this to
play but we have enough go